and while the millions of Americans
being affected in a real financial way
by the crisis see concrete action out of
Congress that Kevin was just talking
about there is bipartisan opposition
tonight to the relief plan that passed
over the weekend with Republicans and
Democrats pushing for more help for
ordinary Americans while some are
concerned right dad let's talk about
when we might get the package done at
with Senator and dr. John Barrasso of
Wyoming good to have you back senator
thank you Shannon okay so we know that
the house did some technical fixes to
what they passed just a couple of days
ago believe it heads to the Senate
tomorrow what's your take on how it will
be received there and how the vote may
go people are being challenged all
across the country Shannon at a time
like this relief is necessary by the
government we want to do it that doesn't
burden businesses this is a government
opportunity and responsibility right now
to help the American people the workers
the families I expect that this is going
to pass what comes over from the house
but that's only phase two phase one was
the medical component making sure the
doctors and the researchers had what
they needed this is the first step and I
wouldn't be surprised if a Phase three
also passed later this week a much
bigger piece to help our workers because
Shannon with the new things that are
happening around the country people in
restaurants and bars that are out of
work immediately I mean there are
immediate needs and the government has a
responsibility to step in okay senator
excuse me secretary minuchin was quoted
coming out of a meeting tonight I know
he met with a number of GOP senators and
will tomorrow I don't know if you're a
part of that but maybe tomorrow he says
we'll be looking for support for small
and medium-sized businesses we'll be
looking for support for certain
industries that we've talked about that
are particularly hard-hit I've talked
about airlines hotels others and we will
be looking at a general stimulus it is
critical at this moment but there are
those who have raised serious questions
about whether some of these policies
that are very expensive get locked in in
a permanent way even when we're past
this crisis the price tag how do you
answer those concerns well this needs to
be targeted and it needs to be temporary
but you I think of our small businesses
in Wyoming and that's just about every
business in Wyoming you want to make
sure that their employees are
are taken care of but you want to make
sure that by the time this is over that
those businesses have the cash on hand
that they can come back open again and
aren't don't find themselves in a bad
situation so you want to take care of
the employees as well as the small
businesses because it's small businesses
shannon that supply 70% of the jobs in
america but until we get the disease
itself this virus under control and get
beyond the health component of it no
matter what kind of stimulus you apply
that the economy will not recover as the
president said today until we have the
virus under control okay i want to play
something from dr. deborah birx part of
the task force very well-respected
across numerous different
administrations here's what she said
today we have been working on models on
day and night what had the biggest
impact in the model is social distancing
small groups not going in public in
large groups and if they everybody in
America does what we asked for over the
next 15 days we will see a dramatic
difference and we won't have to worry
about the ventilators and we won't have
to worry about the ICU beds because we
won't have our elderly and our people at
the greatest risk having to be
hospitalized senator every country is
different some are more authoritarian in
nature others are more freewheeling
we've seen different results in places
from Japan and South Korea to Italy and
Spain do you think what we're doing now
with the social distancing and
you know the cancelling of all these
major events and now even smaller and
smaller groups and events is gonna be
enough to flatten that curve well I
think it's very aggressive and it's very
appropriate and I believe it will as
long as people cooperate in ways that we
ask folks to do that you know there are
a lot of young people and as a doctor
burse also said it is the Millennials
who will make the difference in terms of
slowing the spread of the disease the
people most vulnerable if they are in
contact are our seniors people who are
older who also have underlying medical
conditions and that's why the social
distancing is so very important
but we look at South Korea you know that
is the model that we would like to have
for the United States rather than what
we saw in Wuhan
and we're seeing now in Italy and across
Europe all right senator we wish you all
the best as you work on these new
packages in the coming days and your
work as a physician as well at this
important time people's people's lives
have been impacted their livelihoods and
been impacted like nothing they've ever
seen before and the government has a
role in providing relief for the
American people at this time folks on
the hill hammering this out the very
bass senator thank you thank you thanks
Shannon